Welcome to English in a Minute.
Have you ever heard this American English phrase?
What's the game plan?
This expression is very common in American English,...
...but it does not have anything to do with playing a game.
It's a way to ask for information.
So, what's the game plan?
What are we doing tonight?
We're not sure yet.
What do you want to do?
When you say, "What's the game plan?",...
...it's another way to ask someone for the details of a plan.
It's the strategy for accomplishing something.
In sports, a game plan is a set of instructions for the players to follow...
...so they can win the game.
Outside of sports, it could be a plan for going to dinner,...
...seeing a play, or even watching a game.
And that's English in a Minute.